still seeing the reports overnight with
russia's
moving on the eastern side
and we will continue to as we've said
all the way through to do everything we
can to support ukraine in in what is a a
ferocious battle with a uh an invasion
beauty is taking forward that is
becoming more about poland by the day if
that's possible
what are we going to do about these two
british fighters that have been taken
hostage well it's dreadful to see
anybody being taken hostage obviously
british forces that's something the
government is always very focused on the
prime minister is continually in contact
with colleagues and partners around the
world both through nato and obviously
directly with president zelinski we'll
continue to do everything we can to
support
anybody
from the uk and anybody actually as we
have done with the ukrainian people in
the work that they're doing to defend
their country in a democratic country
but how much sympathy should we have for
them i remember um the defense secretary
saying at the time that he really didn't
appreciate uh i think it was him or in
fact the armed forces minister saying
you know people going out there just so
they can get selfies to come back how
much sympathy should we have for people
that go when they were told they
shouldn't well we're very look one of
these very clear is this is a very
dangerous situation the armed forces
both ukrainian armed forces and the uk
air forces have their own processes and
procedures people should be following
the law so we should be we are there to
support ukraine we are doing that in a
very practical way as northern ireland
secretary i've been very fortunate to
see some of the work being done in
northern ireland producing the end laws
for example which are being sent out to
ukraine that's what we're doing as a
country and that's the right way it
should be people who want to support
ukraine what we would encourage people
to do is to do it through the right
channels bring that financial support in
as hundreds of thousands of people in uk
are doing rather rather than taking very
dangerous and actually not legal
processes to go out and act in that way
but having said that obviously we want
to see everybody in ukraine being safe
of whatever their nationality and that's
why it's important that russia and
putin's regime pull out of this invasion
but are we involved in trying to get
them back to the uk well i appreciate
you you're pretty sure i'm not going to
comment on what are effectively national
security issues uh what we're saying to
people is you should not be traveling
out to ukraine
because
because i'm not going to comment on
armed forces processes and i'm not going
to they're not armed forces are they
well
we are in an armed conflict in ukraine
and it is right that we continue to be
very clear with people well
ukraine is an armed conflict republican
i'm sure the president of ukraine would
say he's an armed conflict we are
supporting that we're doing that through
the proper process
they are no they're absolutely they're
illegals do we still have a
responsibility to bring them back home
well we always have responsibility for
british citizens which we take seriously
we've got to get the balance right with
ukraine that's why i say to anybody do
not travel illegally to ukraine the
armed forces in ukraine have the support
of the uk we're continuing to put that
support in and that's the right way to
do it people who want to help in ukraine
there are ways to do that both
financially and people who open up their
homes that is not the way to do that i
understand what russia is saying is if
you give us victor medvedek then you can
have these two brits back is that
something that we would get involved
with that sort of negotiation this is an
oligarch who um as we know was an
opposition leader in ukraine for a while
mp there i think at the moment well
we're actually going through the process
of sanctioning people who are close to
beauty regime we're not going to be
looking at how we can help russia we're
looking to actually ensure that the
pewter regime is unsuccessful in this
abhorrent invasion and we'll continue to
do everything we can to support the
ukrainian people ukrainian president and
government to defeat beauty i understand
so these guys are on their own they're
really for now well there shouldn't have
been there is an illegal act to be there
obviously anybody will have sympathy
with somebody who has been taken hostage
but we have got to make sure that we
follow the proper processes that we are
dealing with this in the right way we
give the support in the right way that
the ukrainian armed forces and the
ukrainian government ukrainian people
can make good use of that is what those
official processes are about that's what
hundreds of thousands of people here in
the uk are doing and we should be very
proud of that and grateful for the
people of the uk who are doing that
let's talk about the fact that it's a
thousand days today since boris johnson
became prime minister there was an
opinion poll our yesterday jail partners
um saying the words that were
a bit of water before we go with this
one uh things like the way they
described him was liar that was the most
common word used right in the middle of
this bubble here
followed by incompetent and
untrustworthy
it's not a great look is it buffoon in
there as well
well i work with the prime minister on a
range of issues across the uk obviously
particularly for northern ireland and
i've been working with someone whose
focus has always been on delivering for
people it's been through covered um all
the way through code conception's
reality isn't it and this is what people
think of him well this is why the part
i've got to say the prime minister
himself has been very clear in the
statement he made last week he's
apologized for what's happened he said
he would make changes at number 10 which
he has been making we've seen some
substantial changes there and he's
focused but that you know the key people
choose
five people well he's been he's already
changed the chief staff and some of the
key people around the team in number 10
which he said he would do
he is very much focused on the issues
that are affecting people whether it's
around the cost of living whether it's
around continuing the work as we come
out of covet and supporting obviously
the people of youth but he did say that
he hadn't broken the rules but he paid a
fine
so he must have realized that he'd broke
the rules in order to pay the fine no
why didn't he contest it as he said in
his statement last week the prime
minister's has been because he's a liar
is it no no as he said last week in his
statement and promised we'll be talking
to parliament later today so we'll make
a statement but at every point he has
been clear with what he believes to be
the truth what he's also accepting is
the police have looked into this
particular issue they've taken the view
that fire should be issued he he accepts
that he has paid that fine um he's
apologized for that does he accept that
he broke the rules
well he's accepted that the police have
said that the rules were broken
therefore does he accept that he broke
that he's very different at work it is
very different that's why i'm asking you
he made to parliament was that when he
spoke to parliament he was speaking what
he believed to be the truth and what he
outlined to be the truth that is
absolutely right and proper what does he
do
broke the rules as he said last week he
absolutely accepts the police have found
that the rules were broken to a point
that they issued a fight but it is
because that's why he's paid the fight
and he has outlined that he accepts that
no does he accept that he broke the
rules
well in the sense he's paid a fine that
the police have decided it's issued
because the rules were broken but that
doesn't mean that anything he said to
parliament was inaccurate at the time
why not because what he said to
parliament he believed to be true at the
time on the first of december he said uh
all guidance was followed completely in
number 10 on the 8th of december he said
no party and no covert rules were broken
yeah and he believed that to be
absolutely true what do you think was
happening when there was cake and people
singing happy birthday and drinking beer
what do you think it was as the prime
minister himself was outlined at that
and he did in his statement last week
but he was at work all day he was at
work when people then came in and wished
him happy birthday uh in the same way
that kirsten was at work when he was
pictured having pizza and beer with his
staff but the promises can i take up
with labour later on and
they will be as robustly defending their
leaders as you are defending the prime
minister but of course it's not just one
incident is it but
let me just finish that's why the prime
minister was very clear apartment he did
not believe at that point that anything
he'd done was against the walls but he
absolutely accepts the police have
looked to this they've taken a different
view they've issued a fine he's
apologized he's paid the fine and he has
to be very clear about that yet two
weeks before it's uh suggested in uh
this weekend's papers that he was
organizing the event for lee kane he's
head of comms to leave
so was that a party or not well i have
to we haven't seen that part of the
investigation here we've got to let the
police do their work get to the bottom
let me put it this way then i can only
really i can only comment on what has
been decided yeah so he's broken the law
on on one occasion we know at the moment
can a lawmaker ever be
a law breaker yeah i think look we do
see consistently whether it's through uh
parking fines whether it's with speeding
fires ministers of both parties over the
years
but we've also we've had prime ministers
in the past have penalty notices from
what i can see and
uh correlated to our prime minister
making coveted rules when the country
was in lockdown 120 odd thousand people
have died and you can make the
comparison between the two you're saying
to me i'm asking you if you can you ask
me if somebody who sets the laws and the
rules can also be someone who breaks
thoughts that clearly has happened with
a number of ministers over the years but
tony blair didn't make the rules
well the government is responsible for
all of the rules and regulations so you
could argue that governments don't pass
this some of the specific local fines on
parking but still with the parking fine
it's broken it's still a law of the
country are you completely comfortable
making the comparisons with parking
fines i'm just making the point that i'm
just asking if you are okay
yeah absolutely in the sense that
ministers in the past have sadly been
subject to getting fixed penalty notices
on a range of issues they can continue
to be ministers they do continue to be
ministers i've seen that in both
governments with the previous labour
government as well as the conservative
government the focus has to be on
accepting when you've done something
wrong and lodging that you've done that
which the prime minister has and being
focused on moving forward to do things
in the right way and what he has been
focused on and we have to say all
through kovid through this issue with
russia's invasion of ukraine the work
we're doing on the cost of living at the
moment that's making life difficult with
so many people across the country we've
got a prime minister who's focused on
delivering on those things in a way that
works for people in this country and
that's why he's had my support will
continue to but that's right you know
that's why people think he's a liar
because he says i didn't break the rules
twice he misled parliament some might
say and yet um he still doesn't accept
that he broke the rules
well that's not the case first of all he
hasn't misled parliament he has outlines
upon what he believes to be the case and
the truth at the point he's equally
quite rightly apologized for what has
happened accepted the position the
police have taken and paid the fine and
he is very much folks even on that day
if you look at his dive for the day i'm
focused on the issues that are affecting
people across the country on a range of
things as i say across cost of living
issues with the war in ukraine issues as
we're moving out and we're moving out of
covid and getting our country moving
forward in the way that as men we're
having the success economically that
we're having compared to other countries
if there are any more fines will it be
made public the promise has always been
very clear that he'll be very open about
uh any files that he he was there
anymore we will hear it so no reason why
anything would change he's always been
said he might be very clear and open
about that first and he'll be right he's
actually said that to me so thank you
for the clarification and i just wanted
to clarify as far as the ministerial
code is what's concerned because you
said he didn't break the rules
it features a forward by the prime
minister himself and it says ministers
who knowingly misled parliament will be
expected to offer their resignation to
the prime minister you're saying that he
didn't knowingly mislead them because on
the 1st and the 8th of december when he
said what he said he didn't realize that
when he was in the cabinet room and
potentially other places and there was
cake and goodness knows what else he
didn't realize that was breaking the
rules at the time no exactly what's
happened for him to now realize what he
still didn't think he'd broken the rules
until the police told him well as i said
his viewer when he when he outlined that
department was that he was saying make
making a statement of facts what he
believed to be true that is absolutely
the right thing to do that's what you do
in parliament
and what he has done since then as we
saw last week with the fine from the
police he's accepted the police have
come to view um he has paid that fight
he has apologized um and he is making
changes in number ten as he said he
would to reflect the chances he had
broken the law well as you said when the
police have issued a fine the prime
minister's reception
before then you said that he was
clearing out before then
he accepted before then as we've said
nothing i spoke to you on this program
about this uh who did it before he
accepted that things that happened at
number 10 that people didn't like sure
the question is when did he realize he'd
broken the law when the police issued
him a fine he is accepted why did he
sack people before then because there's
a difference between whether the police
decide if there is a fine to issue
because of what has been broken is
different to whether you realize and
take a view the things that happen at
number 10 and the way things were
happening number 10 was not why it was
not appropriate he took action on that
a fair few weeks ago now a couple of
months ago now as he said he would and
apologized those issues he we outlined
to pardon that his you was that he
hadn't broken any rules that was the
right thing to do that was his belief at
the time he is also accepting the police
have come to a different view on this
particular event they've issued a fine
he accepts that he's acknowledged that
he's paid the fine and apologized